it's on for roses and Rosie men tell o
men tell all men telling o guys I didn't
tell that much okay it was the
bachelorette men tell all I loved it I'm
here for it I got rose a for it let's
dive in everybody
so I usually have my notes on my phone
last week my phone had 12 percent
battery by the end of the night this
week it has two so we printed them out
and they oh Sh I just spilled some rose
a I'm sorry for wasting the bounty that
you gave to I'm so bad with that okay so
these notes they look like some kind of
CIA operative scenario is this bond what
it are they like it's printed front and
back for our box that's a French
reference but we're going to keep on
keeping on like it's 1997 like it's the
first season of The Bachelor here we go
we haven't thought about beefing up
security tonight yeah guess what
they literally allegedly did last men
tell all with chat I even spent an extra
couple days in the gym I just can't tell
okay Chris okay I mean I'm not crazy
okay it's not Chad level crazy you still
set that bar pretty high everybody Oh
but anyway it's the most memorable men
tell all ever
so the guys are introduced in dean gives
a big round of applause sucker
not really Dean frivolous or payer for
batches if you want to know what Dean
things about being the bachelor you can
say with UK online calm that's our first
shameless plug tonight everybody
[Music]
Dean will be on bachelor in paradise and
actually tonight I got a rose a called
paradise paradise paradise in another
language maybe French I don't know I
don't discriminate unlikely I'll get to
it okay we had to get into the blake wu
boom controversy what a joke honestly
don't even my time i love will you guys
remember will will was great and during
this whole episode will laid it down at
a couple of key moments like wah boom
guys trying to talk and will is like you
don't get to call anyone else anything
call anyone else on this stage of joke
say whatever the hell I want you don't
know anything about me okay nailed it
will I don't think real good me on
paradise by wishing was bring it back
for Winter Games is something I love
will I like the mental all special
because you reminded of you know it's
gotten down to the final few guys and
you kind of forgot about these sort of
favorite guys you had like Kenny and
will and and
I'm still T being wearing a camo blazer
I liked it
what is the men tell all for to make
more money on commercials upfront of
Ally oh it wasn't the men too long
Peter crowd so I tried to push through
and did oh you know who was it the men
tell all
does Mario drink everytime jamario kind
of blows your mind
soda Mario they didn't really get into
the paradise thing the paradise thing
was not talked about and guys just see
no I was at the men tell all taping so
paradise not brought up except for this
burn by Chris Harrison when they brought
up to Mario's exit from the show The
Bachelorette over his alleged
ex-girlfriend the fact that I have yeah
is I had this guy de Mario yeah tell me
he dated her and he had been analyzing
to tell you that that's caught up I have
it on tape I do have that on boom boom
no he did it yeah Chris Harrison just
threw it down but again drink every time
to Mario blows your mind
Clinton has disco Monica but do you
fight you tomorrow called that chick a
side chick what was her name lacy sorry
Lacey so all these people kind of sucker
talking and then Janie is like oh it's
funny how these people have sucker
talking and then ever else is like who's
Jamie and jamario put Jamie and is blaze
drink again for Demario blowing our
minds according to meeting online source
reporting Demario is the exhausted do
Dancing with the Stars I would watch
I would watch let me know if you would
leave in the comments below which watch
tomorrow in different societies you
ready for the show let me know he knows
not a bad person
it made some dumb choices you know what
boom you know Li like cut the guy a
break
Oh Dean suspends Demario he's like
jamario is not in the same group as wah
boom orally because
jamario is just an idiot I was literally
deemed defensive jamario he's like he's
not a bad guy just dumb it made some
dumb choices okay you know what nobody
is going to go nobody is going to
question what Dean says the whole
audience reacted so Dean for Bachelor
guys is still up in the air I don't know
Dean himself told me you think he's too
young and I just left Peters so much so
much I just wanted to get weird because
of how much I love Peter eggy is there
looking like Rev Run what is he wearing
so it's interesting to see what the guys
wear the men tell all you know if you
watched Real Housewives it's like what
do they wear to the reunion special
nobody gave jamario apparently the memo
that it was like a suit jacket situation
Demario was there
I don't know ready for brunch yeah whip
it around to the back oh we get into the
van thing this bugs me were so long you
guys when Lee and anyone are two on one
date we alleged that Kenny pulled him
out of a van violently and Kenny was
like that never happened well now we
know the truth
Lee says he did not pull me out of the
van kid I know okay oh he made it all up
and Lee was so interesting all night
long look we knew Lee was going to be in
the hot seat okay and he was and you
know his apparent racism was brought up
you know exactly and like these tweets
that he sends out a year ago were
brought up a question while all the
episodes were airing right you did not
think the social media want to denounce
anything that you were saying or doing
and I felt like Lee did not know what to
say
I felt like we needed a PR team prepping
him a lot better than they did before he
tapes this he was so quiet and
when he was confronted like dude are you
racist that's a hard thing to say it's a
hard thing to say that you were or are a
racist
he was like I have a lot to learn I want
to learn
I'm facetious I wasn't very considerate
I wasn't as considered as I should have
been in a lot of ways okay cool are you
racist or is it a no is it yes
eventually he apologized I should have
been a better friend and I was not that
to you and for that I apologize but did
everybody believe his apology as well I
asked all the men after the special and
you can check out those interviews over
DT online.com that we go I want a Reagan
jerk-off in it hmm nope you can't do it
it doesn't even make physics sense honey
is in the hot seat and oh my god you
guys I forgot how much I love Kenny
Kenny is so sweet and so smart and so
kind and such a good dad and his
daughter was even there and she is so
beautiful and so well-spoken for her age
and oh my god Kenny for Bachelor I don't
know I ask any of you is going to be on
paradise and he said something like
maybe I like sand okay Kenny well I love
Kenny and he's amazing and he's just a
nice in person that he sees on the show
he was pretty good southern accent when
you think incredibly well Kenny if I did
anything to offend you okay I also want
to say I think the guys overall were
really kind of silly more kinds than
they had to be considering what he said
to some of those tweets and they really
treated him with kid gloves and they
were like dude you got to learn and he
was like I got to learn I'm not really
sure exactly where the teachings going
to come from or what specifically he's
going to be like like what book he's
going to be reading I don't believe
things get better really okay Oh Kenny
did the snake move again that was great
what a moment
what things acknowledge it speak it so
yeah everyone's likely are you racist
just say it just say at least he won't
say it he finally apologizes but he
never really said he was racist and
Demario again drink everytime Demario
blows it up when you looked up the next
day and you rate it and you realize you
fit those racist ass tweets did you the
next day the two go
I leave the doubt these tweets or did
you wait a year and nine days to be on
this stage right now and now are you
saying I it was likely you sent those
tweets a year ago
why didn't you denounce them then and we
didn't and you know dubrio said a lot of
weird crap like when he asked for ocular
effect I know what that is but he was
right about the fact that we could have
tweeted a year ago and been like why did
I say that and he didn't and he didn't
tweet during the season being like why
did I say that when he was here and
everybody was kind of like you're only
apologizing now as you have to oh that's
the thing Billy oh maybe my favorite
part was when Lee said I think I don't
like racism at all okay my central plain
drink every time leaves with something
that makes no sense
and then rachel gets in there and she's
like no time for you Lee hmm
Rachel told me she didn't want to give
the least situation any more breaths so
you know what I'm not going to give it
any more breaths here
I just drink without breathing that was
interesting
yeah that's not all their experience
okay at the end of the day the guys
treated Li with love but also put him in
his place and I thought it was a good
combination between the two so Dean Dean
gets up there and Dean is perfect as
always Dean says that you know yes
people criticized him for not speaking
to his dad for two years because
speaking him for the first time on
television and he was like Rachel needed
to know the full scope of my family and
she did get the full scope a Bob Dean
guesses mellow with Rachel and he told
me afterwards and then interviews up a
TV online.com you guys honestly didn't
NFL all make you question you want to be
The Bachelor Dean Kenny it's still
theater in there but Dean gets to
confront Rachel and he's what kind of
onions but he's like he Christmas I was
come up and talk to her about all right
sure and I can sit up there which I love
we'll need you guys it's like they
definitely talked to the producers
reported about who's gonna come set up
there the names like Tigers it up there
and they sit down he's like I don't know
I'm kind of almost a lot further than
now like [ __ ] Dean baby you know you
were going up there
you knew come on find the words and he
could friends Rachel about something we
were all wondering if you said that you
loved me and it got the boot like four
days later you know why did you send him
home and then she do the explanation we
all knew she would I miss it like a
hundred percent like in that moment I
kind of felt that way since the show is
weird guys it's weird your feelings are
weird Demario and Rachel a very little
interaction but she told me that she'd
be okay with everything tomorrow again
find out who else is okay with never
seeing again over TV online dot
ah team madam if you remember everyone
was like why are they still here
the board that they were but Rachel said
look I really did every relationships
with these guys it's unfortunate that
America did not get to see what I had
with each one of you and I said I like
them both and also Adam looks good and
also did not die of eyebrows man look is
so dark I don't know you know what a guy
shaves his beard and you're like you
front of your face so I felt about his
eyebrows did he shave his beard or did
he die his eyebrows please let me know
you think in the comments below the fact
of the matter is out of all the guys and
then the speech from Fred Wow Fred was
the guy who went to camp with Rachel and
she said I can't not see you as this
troubled little kid which I thought was
a little unfair of her during the season
but you know was an unfair Fred to come
with a freaking memorized speech now I
thought because I knew you that I could
bring a level of comfort to you Fred
wrote his lines and he had now in fact
he was speaking in third person so much
at the beginning of this high school
graduation speech but I didn't know if
he was talking about himself there is
one guy who already had them but he was
and Rachel was like and we were all like
I'm the guys before W now it's nice and
nice to the Conservatives or the rose
boys they say delegated attention you
know what comes out of these shows
friendships engagements and friendships
and
and then we got the blue bears which I
loved and who was driving this golf cart
my god
everybody's okay thank God and Dean and
the gully talk about the bloopers but
Dean and the gum yeah that's the one
imperfect thing that Dean's ever done
and who will be getting down on one knee
Chris says all of America is waiting for
the finale of The Bachelorette and you
know what I don't disagree because a lot
of really depressing crap is happening
in our country and I think all of
America needs a happy ending right now
so we're all waiting for the finale and
we didn't get any new footage just got
Peter crowd
crying why aren't they doing this to me
why I can't take it anymore I am under
emotional distress I need therapy
I can't watch Peter cross cry anymore
it's too traumatizing I have PTSD
post-traumatic sexy disorder I can't
handle it don't show me that promo again
don't do it
anyways you guys thank you so much for
being or make sure to like UT on
Facebook subscribe to us on YouTube you
can follow me on Instagram Twitter and
snapchat where we could talk more about
the Bachelorette and of course check out
all the interviews with Rachel and our
guides that we did after mental all over
et online.com I love you I love PETA I
am so Ted's you guys Monday August 7 the
bachelor finale cannot come soon enough
bye this has been driving me crazy I
don't want to get real for a minute
there is some movie where a character
says the name Peter like this PETA PETA
and it isn't plaguing me all season and
if anyone knows what that movie is
please dear God tweet me and let me know
so that I can go to sleep at night